[Music]
i have to put my
tony stark glasses on they're a little
schmutz i will say that my my daughter
just discovered spidey and his amazing
friends like three weeks ago and now
she's obsessed perfect timing huh yeah
my kid was in the mickey's fun house
and he and then i was doing the voice i
do the voice of salty bones on there a
pirate guy
and then he cut sorted out grew that and
went on to spiders amazing friends and
now i'm doing iron man on there looks
like you could use some help iron man
good thing i was in the neighborhood
i wish he would start watching you know
a marvel movie or something where i
would yeah what i mean what is that like
for you as a dad does that does he
recognize it as your voice yeah he you
know he does he's been a few sessions
with me he likes it how old is your
daughter yeah my same
you just want your kid to think you're
cool and i don't know to what lengths i
have to go to to get this kid we were
driving the other day and kokomo comes
on the radio and i said billy isn't that
cool your daddy's on you know played
song on the kokomo here and he's like
takes the longest bass where he goes dad
do you know the beatles
or he'll watch the net i came home and
then nanny was obsessed with full house
for some reason yeah and so she was
showing him full house
and um
he he'll say to him i said clean up your
toys and go yeah you got it dude like
sarcastically you got it dude he'll do
you got it dude as a sarcastic response
to you yeah and then i'll lock him in
his bedroom for a month and then what
does it mean to you well
35 years ago fuller full house premiere
yeah i mean a lot has happened over the
course of those 35 years when you think
back to the early days of of full house
what goes through your mind well it was
magic you know on those shows and i've
been on a lot of shows magic has to
happen the stars all have to line up and
everything has to be perfect at times
but i i think of it fondly i i but i'll
tell you what there's no way we thought
it would be around it you know it seems
like it's a cultural you know
staple of tellers you know the reviews
said it was it was about until
thanksgiving or something like that and
for the longest time it was like i got
to get away from that show and i
realized it's not going anywhere and
then you know you embrace it right i
mean i'm grateful for that show um but
you know what's interesting when it
started you know a family without a
mother and three got you know it was a
little weird but now as time goes on
each year that goes by divorce is bigger
same-sex marriage is bigger so there's
the new normal is not 3.5 kids and a
mother and father we were just all
together at jody's wedding which was
really sweet and i don't know if you saw
the story but absolutely true i'm
running out of the house and i'm wearing
this shirt and kaitlyn was like
that's too tight let's just go get
another and so i ran up and grabbed i
have 8 000 black shirts as usual yeah
and i just went up and grabbed the first
one ran out to the car because we were
late put it on and i'm driving and it
feels big and i when i get there i
looked and i realized because kelly
bob's wife uh gave us a bunch of stuff
and it was bob's shirt
my hand to god and i said and i started
crying i when i realized i said jody
bob's here what do you mean
that's amazing that's an amazing story i
mean i also love that you guys don't
need a special reason to get together
because you're all you all seem like
you're
entwined in each other's lives in such
intimate way in a in weird way weird
like name one show that you know most
shows they're done they hate each other
no it was a special thing and you know
as this as the years have gone by and
how the show's meant more to people you
know we get together more um and we
support each other we've been through
we've been through a lot together we're
all we've always been there for each
other that's the story with bob too and
that's why we all miss him so much
because he was such a large part of our
lives back to today do you do you're
doing a lot of like you're doing all
these voiceovers for these very
very fun shows are you doing it because
of the of your son or is just like
that's what's coming your way and it
happens to coincide
i think it it you know it coincides i
mean it wasn't really a i gotta go get
some voice over i mean i've always
wanted to do it like no one ever just
gave me a shot to do it so it's really
interesting doing the voiceovers i was i
was scared at first because i didn't
know
what i'm gonna do but it's it's really
it's a different process and i do like
it yeah what's it like for you taking
over the role of tony stark it's
absolutely you know astounding what
they've done yeah it's starting that
whole thing with these brilliant actors
like robert downey and gwen genius um so
i did you know i did sort of a deep dive
and i came in with a lot of rhythms and
you know it's tony stark stuff and
they're like no no don't do that don't
do that i mean it's a it's a show for
three-year-olds a four-year-old so you
have to keep it sort of straight but
after a while i realized well this is my
tony stark this is my version of it and
seems to work yeah my daughter for a
while would be like i am i'm gwen stacy
or she was like i'm the black panther
like that's how i get her to do like
like a black panther would brush brush
his teeth right that's right yeah you
use the same tactics on your usually
candy and
disneyland
[Music]
you